anxious to see it the pirates can get
their
first three-game sweep of the season
scope hitless in four trips
last night one for eight in the series
here's the one-two pitch swing and a
miss struck about with that fastball
above the zone knowing how to deliver a
pitch with
you know your maximum stuff
he's been there done that here's robbie
grossman first pitch swinging and
finding a hole on the left side beating
the shift for a two out single fourth
into the series for grossman and here's
miguel cabrera now the payoff from
keller
this is a rocket to right center field
that ball is off the wall grossman's got
plenty of steam he's headed home and
miguel cabrera has himself an rbi double
to get the tigers
on the board doing the job 3-2 pitch
right there again trying to climb the
ladder on miggy and what he does best
right goes the other way inside outs the
ball
he knows it right away he knows he's hit
it good he said get up get up a little
bit
now two away from tying luis gonzalez
for number 18 all time
well keller gives up really just a
ground ball that
got through the hole and then they
double off the wall and right and the
tigers take the early lead okay brian
hayes leads things off against matt
manning at times we've seen him as
really good stuff other times we have
seen him struggle
line drive again this time straight away
center liking that lead off spot in he
takes off does
and he's going to be safe
here's the 3-2
swung on and missed big strikeout from
matt manning on the 2-2
got him upstairs with the slider
manning gets in a little bit of trouble
and then gets himself right out of it
with a couple of big strikeouts standing
high in the zone fell away two strikes
on harold castro keller ready the one
two
right in there strike three call with a
fastball low in the zone here's ben
gamble to lead it off his single
yesterday put the pirates ahead for good
he's got one gear
and he drives this one toward left
center field nearing the notch
so gamble will wind up at second with a
double he was ready to go to third
but it bounces out of play and and
gamble has his fifth hit of the series
nobody out good way to get started
newman one for three with a walk last
night homer the opening game in the
series manning raring back and delivers
the swing of the ground ball through
third and into that base hit newman gets
the job done with a two-out two-strike
rbi single and he ties the game at one
with one run lead they're going to take
their chances of of trying to get kevin
newman out and start the third inning
with mitch keller the pitcher spot up
and and hopefully start the third inning
with one out
it's kind of their mindset it backfired
there
one two foul tipped into garneau's glove
pittsburgh gets the equalizer against
matt manning who leads off the third
taking his first at bat of the year
mitch keller will face his mound
opponent now to start this third inning
matt manning here it is
and the swing of the miss at least he
got a cut struck him out on a pitch neck
high or one out good series for grossman
career high in hits
drives one to right field
and it short hops into tsutsugo's glove
but do all the way to third
first and third for the tigers with two
away runners at the corners for miguel
cabrera who doubled in the tigers lone
run back in the first
slices one to right field he delivers
yet again but drew trouts home grossman
all the way to third miguel cabrera
pours it on another rbi for the big
fella to make it 2-1 boy he's just
looking so comfortable in the box right
here matt manning working with the lead
again we go to the bottom of the third
inning
on the outside corner to get him staring
the 1-1 back up the middle off manning's
foot
and nice play by garneau he popped out
from behind the plate and they got moran
at first
but concern
because matt manning remains down
looks like he pointed to his left knee
as soon as the trainer got out there
manning was pointing to it so where to
get you he's pointed right to his left
knee
and he will gingerly walk off under the
assistance
of the tigers staff all right we'll see
how matt manning's doing we'll keep you
updated 2-1-3
there's robbie grossman who's two for
two
muscles it to left field he's three for
three tigers have a couple of men aboard
with one out that brings up miguel
cabrera who's two for two tigers trying
to add to a 2-1 lead here in the fifth
inning
cabrera right back up the middle are you
kidding me what a night for miguel
cabrera another rbi single he's
blistering the ball all over the
ballpark 3-1 tigers
feeling awfully good
the 1-1 back up the box sent through
into center field another hit for the
tigers
here in the fifth and another rbi this
one to jamer candelario his first of the
series and it's 4-1 detroit there's
robbie grossman robbie's been very
aggressive tonight
a couple of quick outs here
1-0 hammered deep right field that ball
is gone
robbie grossman puts a charge into one
number 22 on the year
swinging again the only reason he didn't
swing at that other one it was in the
dirt
got into a hitter's count 1-0
and didn't miss it what a night for
miguel cabrera and what a night for
robbie grossman four for four night for
robbie grossman a three for three night
for miguel cabrera first pitch to miguel
make it four for four ground ball
singled into center field four four four
for miguel cabrera two nine seven one
on the miggy milestone counter gregory
soto is on for the ninth he'll work
against brian reynolds colin moran and
ben gamel
another payoff man he struck him out
there's the o2
popped it up
behind second base jonathan scope
squeezes it and the tigers
win the series wrap-up 5-1 big nights
from grossman and cabrera and a heck of
a job by the tigers bullpen here tonight
throwing strikes getting outs
but the story of the night really is
miguel cabrera and robbie grossman what
they were able to do in the middle of
that lineup
really impressive and i really think you
look at robbie grossman as well the
unselfish approach to what they're doing
it really kind of resonates i think
throughout the entire
clubhouse
you